welcome to the comma awards
pedro hit it
[Laughter]
[Music]
there we go the comma awards
at your local chili's we're live
everybody
it's me chris head of communications.com
ai
uh we have a lot of awards to announce
today
we actually show you some of these
beautiful awards that we have
to give out look at these amazing awards
3d printed commas they're all silver
they're going to be sent out to the
award winners today
[Music]
we can cut the music
no cut the music
oh here's george's what would the music
go
george is dancing
that's great okay so
we have some honorary mentions before we
really get into the show here
[Music]
all right pedro cut it again this time
for real
okay so yeah we're here by the beautiful
comma christmas tree
even has it has this amazing
3d printed comma star
and look at all the ornaments a lot of
different people
from the open pilot team all here
so let's get on with some honorable
mentions
a lot of great community members this
year and uh you know we just really love
the comic community so much so first of
all there's brisk spirit
this is a new member of the community
who's been making some pretty good pull
requests
we appreciate his attitude and we
appreciate him just jumping right in and
we want that for more people so that's
great
some car porters we have that are really
awesome
mlp is doing some great subaru stuff
over there
jakar did the mazda port which is pretty
cool it's dash cam only since
you have to put a wheel weight on and a
bunch of stuff but we still like the
port
um there's avalaminsky who did the
nissan port and there's a lot of nissans
now actually probably a new one coming
out
very soon the nissan altima shane
does a great fork we'll have more to say
about
chain a little later and then there's c
sours who's been doing a lot more of the
honda bosch stuff
lately reporting some of those bosch
cars and then i also have a shout out
for a moderator
michael does a great job on the
discord so
that is it for our honorable mentions
we're going to hand it off to george
who is going to do some of the big
awards
george it's your turn to announce the
awards
bring up some stuff you know these award
shows gotta take forever
your people aren't here for your
acceptance speeches
so whoa whoa don't show them the script
no they can't see it yeah
yeah yeah you know i don't even know who
wins these things to be honest
uh you know this is like the time my
girl taylor swift hosted the grammys i
need a beer you know
we're gonna go get a beer all right yeah
wait no we'll be right back
we'll be right back with the comma
awards
[Laughter]
all right we're gonna try this uh
stabilizer see how it goes
wait what happened they're not a
stabilizer anymore i'm putting them in
all right um
all right everybody you're going in how
we doing on viewers i added everyone on
discord
202. oh that's pretty good oh
yeah so you know these award shows
uh we like to take a long time
with them no one's here to give
acceptance speeches and that's the thing
we're really dissatisfied about
even though we are far apart you are
close in our hearts
is that what i'm supposed to say here is
that what jim carrey would say is alive
do i know
yeah apparently yes
all right so
um uh we didn't have an envelope
to put them in our chris
community yeah you and michelle okay
good we did that we did that
um george announces winners in this
order
uh what we need what do we need one of
those like tv things where it like comes
across with like the bad font in the 90s
to announce the first award pencilers
of the year
we're going to start for those who don't
know karma pencil
was our channel and discord where
everybody came together and labeled the
comma 10k
uh it's a 10 000
image data set well you guys can add
class labels and this one
if you didn't contribute you had no
excuse
you didn't even need to know how to
program you just needed patience
dedication and time you know all you
people out there were like man i wish i
could contribute something to come
you could have contributed to pencil and
these people did and that's why they're
here today
winning coffee awards so
we're going to start with pj lau
our first commie goes to pj lau he did a
great job coordinating
uh you know a lot of work on commentary
just committed to the repo
this commie right here is for you
this has made a real silver letter
but should we should we put the yeah
we'll spin them this way
if they're digging out okay um
our next penciler of the year goes to
eric b who wrote image labeler the tool
that a lot of people used
uh to label you could have labeled on
the web remember when i said no excuses
people what
excuses are they getting what excuses
are they getting i don't have a computer
i'm not a winner
that's right this is for pj lau and eric
b
this one here goes to someone who's
really
uh picked up the slack on part two
putting a lot of light into a pencil
recently
this one goes to dr
and we have one more one more penciller
one more really
did a lot of work in the last three days
and it's definitely been noticed you
know
the first three people there actually
got sent free combo twos as well
and you keep up what you've been doing
over the holidays and we'll get you one
too
this commie goes to spectre specter 56
this one's for you that is four for the
pencilers of the year
uh if you've noticed that openpile has
improved its lane tracking
uh it's all thanks to the folks in
common pencil will give you the common
tension
uh but for this next one
i think we should roll some clip even if
it's like on a screen let's just make
sure the sound is loud
yeah so this this comedy is for video of
the year
video of of the year video of the year
quick weekly we're all no like with some
sounds
you know the av production team
is um i'm taking a break yeah these
comedies yo
your comments are going to come in the
mail
in the mail in the mail oh definitely
that's that's where they're they're
going maybe while we set that up are
there any questions from the audience
what are they say a lot of excitement oh
a lot of excitement
guys you guys this is just the first
comment you know they don't announce
artists of the year at the beginning
our decade man taylor swift and eminem
were the last two artists
they don't announce that no that comes
later in the awards ceremony we started
off with pencillers
of the year and this one is video of the
year
and it goes to hubble sphere and andy
sly for the open pilot
versus tesla comparison i think we have
some footage right over here
look it's logan would like to read up
and compare the autopilot on my model 3
against the open source open pilot that
he has installed on his 2019 toyota yeah
that's a good video
love that video
[Music]
yes we were really happy with it we're
also happy that we're holding our own
this time
to assist the driver with safety and
convenience apparently almost
a million views logan said that's a
million views wow
man i know battle rappers who would you
know give their left leg for a million
views
um yo so um this one
is for andy sly and this one is for
hubble spear
who made lots of other great videos
logan legrand
make sure to check out his channel uh
yeah
we got some comedies for you guys
oh well that was a video video of the
year so so logan asked if they're real
silver they're real
silver 3d printed yeah silver color
silver color um okay okay
yeah um
this next tommy you know you guys
if you don't win a comedy here tonight
that's just who means you should work
harder next year you know
that that just means that that next year
you can do better
there's there's room for improvement you
know one i heard taylor swift once
talk after she won a grammy she said
it's actually in the reputation
video in that place and she said look
that was all i ever wanted in my life i
don't know what to do from here
but for everyone who doesn't want to
call me here tonight
you have goals and dreams three people
are watching
uh 261 261 that's pretty good
ah this next award
is fingerprinter
of the year
fingerprinter of the year he spent a lot
of time on discord
helping a lot of new people he didn't
have a fingerprint head for their car
get one added he's also a moderator on
our discord
this commie goes to eric mariah
all right yeah we need me to clap crap
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah eric's been with us for a
long time in the community
there's a lot of great work helping new
people uh get started and you know
keeping out
uh you know the the the new people who
are too demanding because you know this
is a hacker community
you get out what you put in
um unlike you know consumer product
but that does not mean we sacrifice on
quality we love we love quality
so we have two other people who manage
to do
so well contributing to open pilot and
that's really what this next section is
going to be about contributors people
who contributed
and written code that ended up in
occupied we ended up in the greater open
power community two of these people
are joining us as interns shane
and yasin we're excited to have you here
next summer
there's no comments for you but there
are internships of course these are paid
internships right here
on site in san diego just like bob
barker shows the showcase showdown
we're here to show the common internship
now
we've saved the best
uh a for last i think we're going to go
over
into our open pilot office and we're
going to review some
contributions real code changes that
landed you know
maybe last year
hey everyone yo hey let us know about
this
this person and what they've done
one person yeah i'm really not sure if
there's one person oh
are they dumb
[Music]
is he one person or is she or are they
so there's like this mysterious party
who like contribute
like more than myself as like a common
employee
in the opera people but that's like a pr
merger like a major pr merger for this
what their commit i'm honored to uh
review this person but now's the time
but
let's go let's go review some of his
latest commit actually
this beautiful camera dp think
let's check this out
[Music]
wow give me some insights as to what's
going on here deeb
i just see beautifully this contributor
signature is
uh red diffs net red diffs and that's
one of the most beautiful things you can
contribute to open pilot
a beautiful red diff yeah i see it it's
looking good
i'm still wondering can one person
really do it
yeah how does one person do all this
that's a real that's a really good
question
yeah he has for they have 112 commits
george george may have just leaked a
little bit of a
george the tc he's trying to
oh it's oh are we ready we're ready
i should have watched that side whoa
whoa whoa whoa we're not ready for that
yet i should watch that
that that segment take my hat off
first for this one all right welcome
we've watched you
go on a journey the last year we've
watched you not just
contribute to open pilot but also
become a better programmer you know what
i say you want to get better programming
for the
program
this company is for dean lee our
contributor
of the year whew
all right whoa look at that yeah it's
definitely a big comedy deal we will be
sending this
to you uh we also have a second one here
we're gonna keep whoever wins the big
comedy contributor of the year
she's going to be giving out every year
this is just the first annual comedy
awards
we're going to keep one here we're going
to write your name on it and keep it for
all-time history
someday when we're worth billions of
dollars you know you go to the google
office you can actually see the first
google data center
and it was a bunch of motherboards
shoved into like a dish rack
so it's going to be like that
thank you all for joining us
uh it's been it's been you know it's
been 2020.
you know that's all i'm going to say
about the year it's been the current
year
yeah you know what what's good about
dean lee he was
he's never been credited in the release
notes but yet he still does great work
wow daily i mean this is really
you know it's really easy to contribute
in open source if what you're
contributing is a feature that you want
a lot of my pull requests other open
source projects are features that i want
or
bug fixes that i care about but when you
go in and refactor
that shows dedication um and it is
legitimately the best way to get better
uh you know you can have it's a it's a
programming education it's better than
any programming education you're going
to get
um anywhere and the beauty of
contributing
is you get feedback you get feedback on
what's good and feedback someone's bad
and you've just watched uh you need to
come
yeah i mean and that's you know that the
the dedication
uh yeah you know i will try open pile i
will try i will try i would love to try
it
i would love to try um no and you know
we would love to attract
more people like that to up a pilot uh
it's like getting in on linux early you
know
imagine you could have gotten in you
could have written rise or rise or f out
maybe that was a bad example you could
have written ext4
uh the riser at fast points riser
uh
um yeah i think that's
all we have for you today yeah thank you
for watching the comments this is gonna
be an annual thing
we appreciate you if you contribute we
appreciate you if
you purchase we don't appreciate you if
you complain
uh but we do appreciate appreciate you
constructively
and we definitely appreciate you you
contribute and make pull requests some
comments
slash open pilot you do that you're
ahead of the car companies
you know all right
all right let's hear some award show
music
dean lee hold on
[Music]